citizens of the reject Nation it's me
Tara Erikson alongside this guy Andrew
Flash Gordon wow out with a flash in
with a flash I don't know we're watching
The Corpse Bride you guys Tim Burton the
Corpse Bride I'm pretty excited about it
I am so excited I'm a nerd I've listened
to Pandora's Danny Elfman radio so many
times so I've heard one song from this
film I can't wait I'm so excited I like
how he tells you guys he's a nerd like
we didn't already know leave a like
leave a comment and also don't forget to
ring the
bell ring the bell also thanks to
prepper for helping us edit down these
highlights we love you so much also if
you're not a patron yet we call you
super sexy over there and everybody
wants to be called super sexy also you
can syn up with your own copy and watch
along with us corpse Pride with me and
this guy and also don't forget that GRE
and John offer exclusive highlights and
watch alongs over there on patreon so
get sexy get super get super sexy get on
the patreon are you ready want a corpse
R let's do it
okay oh that's so Tim Burton animation I
love
it dude's an artist
first Emily
Watson Albert
[Music]
finny oh this is a great tracking
shot
looks like he's very content with his
job yeah he kind of reminds me of the
chef from um uh Ariel yeah oh Le yeah
yeah yeah I said Ariel The Little
Mermaid I knew what you were talking
about their head and
I it's a beautiful day it's a rather
nice day day for a
glorious every last little every single
tiny microscopic little must go
according to plan come on dear you go
it's not me it's my dress's
called fish
Merchants it's a terrible day now don't
be that way terrible day for a wedding
it's a sad sad State of Affairs exact
opposite yeah love it how could our
family have come to this to marry off
our daughter to the new single tiny
microsc was interesting the D between
according to plan our family LED from
the depths of
De this feels like the Haunted Mansion
yeah what if vict and I don't like each
other as if that has anything to do with
marriage yeah what is liking someone
have to do with anything get those
corsets laced properly I can hear you
speak without gasping yeah I'm pretty
sure that's the actress who plays the
one of the aunts and James in the Giant
Peach at least it sounds like her I
assume you've seen James and the Giant
Peach I haven't you got to see that I
always knew I deserve better than a fish
Merchant's life but I've never even
spoken to her well at least we have that
in our
favor what it's sweto shy is yeah
everything must be perfect perfect
that's why everything every last little
every single tiny microscopic must go
take it away
Terra why you must be Miss Victoria oh
yes I must say you don't look a day over
no well the good news for him is at
least he's marrying for money yeah
there's a bright side there he doesn't
know her but he's getting money money
makes things easy easier oh yeah makes
you
[Music]
happy he plays music he's a music
man do forgive me you play beautifully
oh I I I do apologize Miss OT how rude
of me too so
shy mother won't let me near the piano
music is improper for young lady what I
always hoped to find someone I was
deeply in love with someone to spend the
rest of my life
with silly isn't it yes
silly no not at all no oh oh dear I'm
sorry wow she really looks like she's
into him what impropriety is this
seriously get away from that piano here
it is 1 minute before 5 and and you're
not at the rehearsal Master gowells is
waiting oh boy come at once her mother
seems so lovely Oh Yeah from the
beginning such a sweetheart
again with this hand that's Christopher
Lee talking such an iconic voice your
cup will never empty for I will be your
wine with this candle I will later this
year he played his father and willly W
or Charlie Chocolate Factory H with this
candle this
candle this candle god that light looks
so real it really does actually
apparently I'm a day early for the
ceremony it's he from your side of the
family I can't recall Emil a seat for
Lord
Baris huh do you not wish to be married
Master VOR what no I meant no I do not
not wish to be married ah have you even
remembered to bring the Ring The Ring
yes of
course is dropped the ring this boy
doesn't want to get married oh
dis excuse
me oh oh my God he's making a great
first impression oh yeah although I
don't feel bad because she's awful yeah
oh I hope it doesn't st stop rning
it he's like this is the most
entertaining rehearsal I've ever been
to
[Music]
on Oh I thought that would make it worse
such a waste of wine this wedding cannot
take place until he is properly
prepared feel like the only nice one
besides him is is uh is the woman he's
going to marry with this hand I will
take your wine almost feels like the
same forest from Nightmare Before
Christmas remember where he found the
the seasons to go to a lot of the same
yeah it has that Vibe with this
hand I will lift your Sorrows your cup
will never empty for I will be your wine
there you
go with this ring I ask you to be my
what uhoh does that mean like cuz he
actually did it and put it on that tree
that the tree is going to become
[Music]
okay
ow oh my God
awesome oh I guess that's why they call
it the Corpse Bride yeah
well hello there well hello beautiful oh
I do they're married now I guess they
are
[Music]
yeah wow she legitimately looks like
she's
glowing H awesome awesome
[Music]
shot it was a dream
ah it wasn't a
dream I mean I know she's got a big scar
in her face but she's she's pretty cute
she's
[Music]
pretty whoa a new arrival he must have
fainted are you all right what what
happened by joke interesting setup for a
film yeah wait did she take him into the
underworld or guess the newly wet newly
wet in the woods you said your fow so
perfectly wake up wake up wake up you
know him fainting is something that
reminds me of Sleepy Hollow which Tim
Burton also directed his character kabad
crane fainted so many times in that
movie so it's just like a Johnny Depp
Tim bur thing for him to faint yeah
where am I that's kind of a long story a
tragic tale of romance passion and a
murder most foul this is going to be
good that's cool
yeah this one I have not heard thank God
there's one tell you a story make a SK
Cry of our own jubilicious lovely C's
bride but I like it I really do
too
kind of reminds me of like when Oogie
Boogie starts
singing I had a feeling you were going
to go there I really I was thinking the
same thing
Beauty Str came into tow down in his
cash and our poor little that one's just
a little more Sinister but yes with a
plan to just the tone and the the vibe
of it
yeah
guys definitely going to get ahead in
life
that's
cool come on boys pick it
up I love the animation so far and the
way that they play with Lighting in it
is brilliant very inventively
[Music]
creative oh that's nice that's awesome
she's like okay my head stays on me
thank you yeah on ay night at a she was
ready to go but where
was Shadows what man and then baby
everything oh is that Jack the Ripper
you think that's Jack the I don't know I
think it's the guy who went to their
remember at the wedding and put out
poured out with the
wine I think it's him he's just creepy
remember they he waiting in the shadows
and they also said too to him is he the
list all right just let him in that's
right I think it was him we're calling
it in fact when he was a boy he yourest
combinations
end oh this guy the possible deleter
thank you you are a most gracious htis
okay I think it's up which is why it
pains me to be
thereof such bad news believe that's
Richard eant would you care to repeat
tonight night's headline for us he he
Victor man D seen this night on the
bridge in the arms of a mystery woman
the darkhair temptress and master v d
Slipped Away into the night and now the
weather scar
follow the town crier probably just had
a slow news day you know how it is you
need something to cry about regardless
We Are One groom short for the wedding
de yeah it's tough to have a wedding
without a groom
yeah you kind of need those yeah
absolutely don't give us a chance to
find him we beg of you just give us
until dawn very well till
dawn so we think that he killed the
Corpse Bride now her initially the the
the one that Richard Grant is uh the one
who poured the wine right yes yeah I
think it was him at least from the shape
it looked like and also of how Sinister
he appears to be yes he's getting away
quick quick
[Music]
Victor thank you you can buy a second
hand did you tell who the voice of the
corpse R is I want to say it's Helen
botom Carter it is right yeah
yeah excuse me
excuse
cool I would never sleep right
again time
I'm curious how she brought him down
there cuz he is alive cuz he's alive I
was thinking that too like how are they
not like uh I don't know like how does
the world not reject him this is your
home now but I don't even know your name
it's Emily I have something for
you it's a wedding present
[Music]
uhhuh thank
you how it a little dog
a a no but come yeah good good good it's
still cute I don't care what anyone says
that looks just like zero in the Haunted
Mansion Nightmare Before Christmas yeah
I mean not just like it but you know
some a little bit my dog
scraps oh oh he loves him no but I think
that was his dog that was that was his
dog oh my God that passed away my good
boy sit see sit scraps oh that's so
sweet good boy scraps roll over roll
over good boy scraps a good gift that
was the best gift ever we need to go up
to visit the land of the living land of
the living why go up there when people
are dying to get down here a Wayne you
can hear it yeah that's great I love him
oh he's my favorite Alfred surely there
must be something you can do let me see
what I can do sweet old man a Ukrainian
haunting spell Ukrainian haunting spell
ah oh not the bird oh okay oh Oh I
thought they were going to like
sacrifice it or something I thought too
the head when you want to come back say
Hopscotch Hopscotch that's
it seems easy enough wa that looks
awesome is she going to regenerate her
skin no no oh no she's not blue is she
where is she I've spent so long it's
hard to tell with the lighting i' almost
forgotten how beautiful the Moonlight is
that's a beautiful shot with her her
fabric is always flowing I don't know
how they do it but it looks beautiful
would have been cool if he would could
have brought his dog with him but it
makes sense why he's not why they didn't
do it
[Music]
yeah oh she's going to be able to ident
if she wasn't hit from behind from the
the guy who oh she'll be able to be able
to identify yeah I should prepare mother
and father for the big news I'll be
right back okay oh
boy you know that shot of the that shot
of the town or the it almost reminds me
of Edward scissor hand's Castle oh yes
that just that shot absolutely I'm sure
he has a perfectly good reason for
taking so long why don't you go ask him
all right I will after all he couldn't
get far with those cold feet sorry just
getting back into pick out what I think
it looks like maybe I'm stretching on
this one but it almost looks like the
snake a little Beetle Juice maggot
little bit little bit this morning I was
terrified of marriage but then on
meeting you I felt I should be with you
always that our wedding could not come
soon
[Music]
enough oh no she's going to see
what darling who's this who is she I'm
his wife she's dead
[Music]
look
oh Victoria W cool
shot oh so he was not he was Oh I
thought he actually really cared for her
just to get back to that other woman
don't you understand you're The Other
Woman No you're married to me she's The
Other Woman a who knows but we're just
too different I mean you're dead you
should have thought about that before
you asked me to marry you why can't you
understand it was a mistake I would
never marry you oh rude Victor oh those
girls are 10 a penny you've got so much
more you've got a wonderful
personality this is the song I've heard
she doesn't compare but she still
breathes
there unimportant overrated overrated
indeed you could see how special you can
[Music]
be I love the songs in this movie so far
hard to compare to night amas those are
just iconic but these are good these are
good
am
tears a that's sweet we have to help him
the Scandal Oh Come set in your chair
dear you're shaking like a leaf F her a
straight jacket she's completely mad so
rude in that sweet little old lady oh
locking her in there oh my gosh what are
we in Cinderella land now seriously I
can't imagine why she wanted to get
married and not be with her mother
anymore
[Music]
goodness
thank goodness your father's short
didn't see your legs what are you doing
here you should be at home prostrate
with grief
P I have to ask you something this is
most irregular please I like his pajamas
yeah please it's Victor he's married to
a corpse he has a corpse bride this is
interesting her mind is Come Undone I
fear thank you so very
much take her to her room w
I am not married I was betrothed some
years ago but tragedy snatched my Young
Bride away oh okay it was him oh there
must be another way without your
marriage to Lord bis we shall be forced
pendis into the street we are destitute
Victor van daughter's gone child you
shall marry Lord Baris tomorrow yeah
it's not that big of a deal he's old and
he's a murderer not a big deal yeah may
you silence that blasted
cofin is he smoking on the job he's
dying on the job my
man oh yeah he oh my God he might he
really might be he is dying on the job
okay he's trying to kill us that's a
great shot oh she plays piano too yeah
remember because they were like she
probably doesn't sing or dance the
Victoria and I was like oh when is she
going to sing and dance for
him
H
yeah it's like it and Adam's family or I
mean thing excuse me not it
[Music]
thing oh somebody died new recruit oh is
it maybe the guy who fell off the cart
the driver oh yeah might be I'm so sorry
oh yeah actually though I feel
great can finally breathe Miss Victoria
yes yes how is she well she's getting
married this evening what married to who
some newcom Lord somebody or other oh
Emily's going to know that name now I
feel like I'm caught in the tide called
out to seea maybe to land somewhere
better I just wish she wasn't so nice
cuz I feel bad like I'm so conflicted I
want Victor to to like I want him to
marry both of them honestly it's sad
it's so conflicting yeah with this ring
I ask you to be
mine oh God it's like when Lydia was
almost forced to marry be juice you feel
so bad like forced marriage my de we
have to talk let me tell her please let
me tell her oh no what's wrong there is
a complication with your marriage oh the
vows are binding only until death do you
part death has already parted you oh we
have to kill him what Victor would have
to give up the life he had forever oh
and drink from the wine of Ages
poison this would stop his heart forever
I want him with Emily but that's a
that's a tough ask she's not you don't
have to yeah she wouldn't do that I'll
do it what if you choose this path you
may never return to the world above do
you understand I do yeah but you have to
reveal that she's marrying that that
monster first so you can save her
yeah I'm like how how's that going to
come about we're moving this wedding
party upstairs upstairs I didn't know we
had
upstairs sounds creepy let's
go you know who should uh be the
official for them Jack Skellington ah
yeah that would be
great feels like the birds in Cinderella
who fix her up her
dress guity
why can't spiders ever do this with my
suits this is so unfair a wedding cake
is no mistake it must be quite Sublime
they're missing something try some Dash
I wish I have more time perhaps there's
something I can do these bones might
help a
[Music]
bit I love how all the drinks here are
like basically tapioca pudding that's
the best kind of drinks yeah
[Music]
oh is her leg gonna like a call back to
her leg come off and he's gonna maybe
he'll help
[Music]
her that's so sweet never seen a maggot
cry it's
cute this seems like such a cheery yeah
wedding it seems like somebody died
which is obviously Victoria's heart and
possibly about to happen to her soon too
true oh what
oo
[Music]
spooky oh
sorry did I miss something and why
they're there I don't know why uh I mean
I know they said they were going to move
the wedding but right
fin oh where do you keep the
[Music]
spirits is It Something I
Said in other news the the
Earth you don't have to say it so
psychotically just say it like the dead
walk the earth that's his whole vibe
[Music]
man
is it going to hug
it
a
[Music]
yeah oh he's been dead for 15 years
frankly my dear I don't give
a oh looks like Frankie Frank Frankie
weenie Frankie
weenie oh there's another wedding who's
is it yeah oh God do she have to like
watch them get married now you came okay
so that's why they came to to go there
to get married
okay oh that's so
cute I do feel bad for Victoria that
she's got to watch this and be married
to that evil guy I know right that's why
I'm like there has to be some resolve
something going to happen here your cup
will never empty for I will
[Music]
I will be your
wine she's not going to let him drink it
my dreams were taken from me now I've
stolen them from someone
else I love you
Victor but you're not
mine
Victoria this so
sweet
oh my goodness I was not expecting this
she's still my wife I'll not leave here
empty-handed you yep
Emily you I left
you f dead ow huh we called it yeah I
think it was pretty obvious though take
your hand off
her do I have to kill you
too oh y scraps good
scraps
yeah sorry it's a dingle
hopper oh is he going to drink some give
him give him give him the give him the
[Music]
poison did he stab the corpse oh no she
stabbed him oh oh oh yeah oh she took it
from oh okay touche my
dear get out but first a toast Emily he
doesn't know it's poison can a heart
still break once it stopped beating I
don't know you tell me yeah enjoy the
drink sir Karma you are no longer living
bye-bye buddy I want to see him
[Music]
die
Justice yep you're right he's all
[Music]
yours
Karma oh Victor I never thought I'd see
you
again oh that's so sweet I'm so
conflicted oh this would have been so
much easier if they would have made
Victoria mean and
[Music]
awful beautiful imagery yeah oh wow did
she just turned into
butterflies she turned into butterflies
oh I love it so much would assume her
soul is being set free because the the
guy drank the poison
yeah beautiful really is beautiful
expecting to see the Batwing in the moon
it's a Tim Burton film after all I one
can dream hey I want to see the wedding
I want to watch that movie too
yeah that was so fun that was very cute
it was adorable it was really it was
super cute I mean it's so Tim bertony so
from start to finish just Whimsical yeah
yeah no for sure it was so timbery I
think the biggest um issue with uh and
again I I didn't really read the reviews
or anything I would say I would assume
this movie was compared like crazy to
nightmare before Christmas which I can
understand I mean obviously Tim Burton
didn't direct A Nightmare Before
Christmas uh Henry cich who did James
and the Giant Peach uh as well um but
Tim Burton was the producer he was the
animator I mean obviously Danny Elfman
came up with all the did the soundtrack
and the song so I understandably so it's
I I get why the comparisons were made um
hard to compare anything with Nightmare
Before Christmas is one of the best
animated films ever in my opinion yeah
um having said that if you don't play
the comparison game I really enjoyed
this you know the film was about
kindness and true love yeah and I I just
I thought it was so sweet and endearing
and I really just love the journey we go
on with Victor and with Emily and also
Victoria just was so heartbreaking in
the end I'm like like I said said if
Victoria was awful and mean it would
have been such an easy decision but
that's life sometimes you know whether
you're alive or you're un alive um but
it was just again it was just such a
beautiful um and Charming sweet film and
I just love so many different things I'm
going to go more into it but what did
you overall think I I really love the
ending a lot like that is why I really
like this movie in the beginning I I
think if we had gotten to um the
underneath there was something about it
that it felt like a little slow to me um
uh just in the beginning but I still
really enjoyed everything especially
like how in the beginning it's very
muted very dark coloring and then he he
goes to the to the down below is what
I'll call it it kind of like brightens
up especially when he meets um Emily
yeah Emily yes uh and then I I really
love how they build up their
relationship we get to see that and then
the struggle obviously with Victoria in
the up above yes uh the Jos of the of
the two of them is fun to see even
though they seem very similar uh they
did set up with the song saying that
just because you're dead doesn't mean
that you're not worth it and she did get
a little size of life to see that she
was worth it because he was willing to
kind of like give up his life and marry
her um and I do think he kind of was
starting to fall for her right it seemed
like he had feelings for her but not
nothing as strong as he did with
Victoria yeah um which I just I really
like seeing that it's like she got to
have one last little love right before
she was actually set free and her making
oh what are you it said Terra oh one of
the songs in the movie was called Terra
theme it said yeah I swear I swear it
said that I was trying to pause it and
click on it for you oh my God it said t
a r a theme I love it I was going to say
that has to make it one of your favorite
movies ever now now sorry I didn't mean
to cut you off but it said Terra them I
had to point that out for you you had to
I was like what is he what what is this
guy doing over here what am I looking at
ter theme I that I noticed I'm so sorry
you're good I mean I just was going to
say that I really like that she had kind
of a she got to be a bride close to
being she F I think she felt probably
loved by him for a second she felt some
comaraderie some partnership before she
was set free which I I really like she
needed to meet him in order to meet the
jerk off and then you know he dies uh I
like the ending the most that she made
the decision once she saw Victoria walk
up she was like yeah I can't do this
you're not actually mine I really like
that they didn't write it that it was
because of anything else but it was
simply her decision because there's only
one way that Victor would actually go
okay I'm GNA marry Victoria who I really
do love is if she Emily really did say
it no this is it's not right because
even after that he went I made a promise
and she was like you already carried
through with it took off her ring he's
very loyal so I really the ending Bravo
it it really tucked at the heartstrings
I was like I really wasn't expecting
that um it again I was very conflicted I
wanted him to end up with both even
though I know you can't end it like that
it's I was like maybe he goes downstairs
to Vis like go
it's a it's a Mormon type of uh type of
marriage um but yeah no I I thought him
and Emily both had very interesting arcs
uh I mean just from the perspective of
you know right away how like yeah he
felt something towards her and then you
know when she gave him scraps I thought
that was so beautiful and sweet I was
like At first like wait what is she
giving him and then it took me a second
to process that that was his old dog
which was so wonderful and that was a
cool I would assume that's some kind of
an Easter egg because I know Franken
weenie is that what it's called yeah I I
haven't I have not seen that film I
think I have either but I recognize the
but the do and I know I believe Tim
Burton did make that film as well so I
believe that's I know that was a short
of his before he even made it but um
anyways um I just thought that was so
sweet so endearing to him um and then
but again it makes sense that he was not
willing to at first give up his entire
life and you know he did feel a certain
sense of something towards Victoria cuz
she was very nice and also too I thought
it was really interesting as well that
uh him and Victoria come from completely
different parents I wouldn't say that uh
you know Victoria's dad is like the
worst thing ever the mom is awful she
terrible um the dad I just felt like is
more of a victim of a controlled in a
controlled marriage controlled
relationship yeah in a controlled
relationship rather so I mean he's just
you know just like playing a part in
that um but um you know he seemed more
on the chill end it's just like I said
he's just just more of a victim at that
point but again I just felt it was
interesting just seeing the dichotomy of
the two like again uh Victor's parents
just more on the hey we want to be more
upscale and get our son like you know
married to to a family who again is more
in the upscale site even though
apparently they didn't really have money
either right um so but again just seeing
how Bo how nice and sweet they both are
even though they come from completely
different uh backgrounds and parents I
thought that was really cool too but uh
I also Lov like again with Emily with
her uh Arc in terms of like how she
really wanted and again makes sense like
as he put the ring on uh her graveyard
or wherever her hand was um cuz I would
assume that's where that jerk off did
the deed is in that is in that spot spot
by that um but yeah no just like the arc
that she goes through where she does
want to love him and then you know she
goes the I guess you would call it the
the Beauty and the Beast like I love him
so I can't make him make her do this
type of thing you know um um you know I
thought that was very it was very mature
and again that's that's where I come
back to like it really is about kindness
and true love like making the sacrifice
for the one you love and I really did
feel and again this movie wasn't that
long I I actually wish it would have
been a little longer um if if I had one
little uh complaint yeah you make a good
point it was a little bit slow at the
beginning they were setting up the whole
world and all that um which I was just
appreciating all the animation I'm like
I I didn't care I didn't care that the
pacing was a little bit slow to begin
with it was a little bit dragging but
that's fine because I was just
appreciating all the Tim animation and
art it was like I didn't care at that
point um but once the story really got
going like especially in the underworld
or whatever you call it that's like when
it really that's when it really kicked
like kicked into gear for me um but yeah
no I just I I just appreciate how mature
the storyline got and it it it got
really I know this is a very Tim
burton-esque thing to say it got really
dark at times too um but yeah it was it
was incredibly deep deeper than I
thought it was going to be in certain
especially with the uh the story line
with Emily and Victor I just I really
was not expecting it to go to that level
I I I didn't really know anything about
the movie other than was called Corps
right and some of the songs but um it
was just a lot deeper than I was
expecting a lot I I can't say a lot
darker than I was expecting it's the Tim
Burton film so I mean you know you know
what you're GNA get with the Tim Burton
film in terms of Darkness but um yeah
just I really love that relationship I
did like the relationship between Victor
and Emily or excuse me Victor and
Victoria I like that just adding the a
at the end uh Victor and Victoria as
well um and I was rooting for them but I
was also extremely saddened and but it
was it was very heartfelt when she did
turn into the butterflies as well that
you know you did feel a sense of relief
that finally she was Avenged as you
would say uh you know that that jerk off
was uh you know taken care of uh if you
will and um you know she was set free
and you know she knew that he did love
her back so you know she felt the sense
of camaraderie uh and love that uh
Victor did feel that way towards her so
that was that was really sweet and again
I just I really did love this film and I
love the songs in it too the animation I
me he knew half the songs already I
didn't know all the lyrics of course but
I mean yeah now you get to match the
lyrics the movie yeah now when I because
a lot of the when I listened to Danny
Elfman radio on Pandora which mostly I
only listen to it at the gym a lot of
the songs on there come back to uh they
play a lot of the same songs in repeat
and a lot of songs on there are uh well
I mean they play h z they play so many
different composers but mostly Danny
Alman and a lot of them are from Corpse
Bride so uh you know there was a few I
when I said the one song at the
beginning it was that one song that
underrated or overrated whatever that
was the one lyrics song but I had
forgotten that there were a few you know
songs with no lyrics I had I had
forgotten but then as I that piano song
that they both I loved it that but that
was that was a great I I forgot to
mention that when we were just talking
that I love that they were like finding
a way to kind of just you know what's
the word I'm thinking of just like find
a way to connect with each other through
playing the piano like cuz that's
something they both love to do we saw
that Victor love to play the piano when
he was uh with Victoria for the first
time she's like your playing is
beautiful and that's something clearly
Emily liked to do when she was alive so
I just thought that was a way for them
to connect because we know that in
animated films that Tim Burton works on
he loves incorporating songs which is
great but actually having them
physically play the piano as a and
making it a storyline for the characters
to progress in terms of the relationship
and connection I thought that was a
beautiful thing to do that moment also
made it where they they do a really good
job of pushing it like past the
threshold of like wait which is the
right choice now because him and
Victoria have like a Vibe and I think
they they fell for each other but then
he meets Emily and there are all these
characteristics that like oh we're
getting around to like maybe he could
also fall for her too they do a good job
of carrying through it's like well
what's the right choice like our moral
guide from the audience has tested a
little bit towards the end once once
we're kind of juggling both and we feel
bad for Victoria that she has to marry
that the the jerk off guy um that we're
kind of we're we're placed in this
position of like but Victor has a really
strong moral code too there's got to be
some way that like like he might help
her didn't come down to him simply came
down to to Emily and I thought that was
really just a beautiful like part but
again it's a very good thing that he
accidentally stumbled onto Emily's
graveyard and that happened because that
jerk off would have probably killed
Victor totally I mean he wasn't just
there randomly um so he probably would
have done that and then he probably
would have taken care of Victoria at
some point too so it's a good thing that
accidentally that all happened because
they all got to have their happy ending
so to speak you know in in a sense so I
love that even if you would have killed
him he still would have died penniless
cuz nobody had any money like literally
no one in this had money yeah yeah which
we saw in the opening shot or one of the
opening shots with Victoria's father
they were cleaning out the safe there
was cobwebs inside the safe there was no
money in there like so really when it
gets down to it they all are truly
marrying for love cuz I think Victor and
Victoria probably knew that they neither
have neither have cash flow maybe they
didn't know but now they do but it's
fine they have yeah and I think Vic from
what I remember at the beginning
Victor's family is in some kind of fish
business right or something like oh so
maybe they have some some C but nothing
like nothing too crazy nothing big yeah
nothing big but uh man that shot at the
end when when
uh yeah when she is walking out and the
moon and just her dress is flowing and
then she the butterflies just go up it's
it's the art in this film is gorgeous
the way that they play with light and
and the animation I also just love when
the tears come down like to me I don't
know why it's just so pretty not only
not only that there were a couple shots
when they were actually having flames
and it legit looked real it was it was
incredible I mean just and the and the
lighting in the film too there was I
mean it was just a really gorgeously
shot film and there was a couple shots
too that I really appreciated as well
most of the cinematography I in this
film there were a couple shots that I
had again just no recollection coming to
mind right now Dutch shots where they
were zooming in like I've seen Dutch
shots before but not Dutch shots where
they're zooming in so I thought that was
a very artistico and a zoom in and it
did land at a Dutch angle in that one
over the head shot there was a lot going
on that I'm like only you can do that
with animation right and make it just uh
really pulls you in yeah no for sure but
uh I'm so glad I finally got to watch
that film I would say if I have to make
a comparison not doing The Nightmare
Before Christmas hell no um but if I'm
going to do a Tim Burton Johnny Depp
2005 comparison I would say I probably
like this more than Charlie in the
Chocolate Factory which is not a big
stretch haven't seen that one so I will
say I will say this I know a lot of
people crap on Charlie and Chocolate
Factory rightfully so because Johnny
Depp is so damn weird in that which I
know Willy Wonka is supposed to be damn
weird I get it although Jee Wilder is
way better in my opinion um I love that
movie actually Charlie in the Chocolate
Factory literally up until the point
until Johnny Depp shows up um but before
that I love that movie it's just until
that point which is supposed to be I got
to watch that movie yeah you should
react to it I I think it'd be a fun
reaction though but I mean don't I don't
want to influence you in any way you
might love Johnny Depp I'll just be like
I'm not gonna pay attention Andrew hates
this movie no no no no no I don't I
don't hate the movie I just I just I
love it just up until the point that
that Willy Wonka comes in but so I would
say the movie is okay okay the but the
visuals and the art Direction and the
production design in that movie Chef SK
but uh I I definitely like this movie a
little bit more I like this movie I mean
I would I would give it around like a
seven
6.57 there's something about the
beginning I don't know why it felt slow
but once it got going and the ending
maybe I'll go with seven seven and a
half I mean I just there are so many
other movies that I'm like well that I
love that I'm like oh I got to save the
upper the upper Stars
so I'm in that genre and I did I did the
great music and the way it shot it's all
beautiful there was just something about
the pacing in the beginning that I was I
it's a little slow it's just a little
slow that's all no I feel you um so
Nightmare Before Christmas is in the
9.51 range yeah um I think that's for
most people this one I would probably
say like in the 8 to 8.2 so I'm
definitely going in the upper echelon so
it's not in obviously in The Nightmare
Before Christmas but it's still 8 to 8.2
is still pretty good score I'd say a
pretty good oh yeah the score I would go
up to like eight based but me the whole
movie for me personally I'd be like
seven and a half so yeah I will say this
too I'm probably I mean I don't know
would you call this a Halloween type
film I would either way I'm going to
start kind of but like either way I'm
going to start watching this from this
point forward in the Halloween Seas yeah
just it's it's in fun little short
little like it's quick yeah yeah I agree
I think it's good all right well those
are any last flots before we get out of
here uh no just if you guys uh want us
to do any other Halloween films Frank
and weeny or any other uh Halloween type
films Tim Burton esque films there's so
many Tim Burton films Sweeney Todd Big
Fish other ones I have not seen I'm not
sure about you but many many others I
still have I don't think I've seen
Sweeny to I have a feeling like I have
big fish I think I it has e and McGregor
right yes it does then I think I've seen
that I've just heard the music music
obviously Danny Elfman radio thank you
um but there's many other Tim Burton
films I have not seen so if there's any
other ones that you want either of us or
any of the on the team who have not seen
any of these films let us know in the
comments and what do you guys think of
Corpse Bride As this uh one of your
favorite Tim Burton films Tim Burton
Johnny Depp uh ones oh and also to I
have not seen uh what's what's the one
uh Ed Wood I have not seen Ed Wood have
you seen that you're like what's this
movie I don't even know what that is
it's um one one of my dad's favorite
movies ever it's Johnny Depp and Tim
Burton it came out I believe
1994 it's a black and white film and
it's one of the worst directors in in
the it's like a bi biography film it's
one of the worst directors in Hollywood
history um so yeah my dad has been for
years like ostracizing me have you not
seen Edward it's one of my favorite
movies ever so let us know in the
comments if you want us to watch any of
those movies I just mentioned or any
other Halloween films love to know
though what you thought of this film as
well leave a like leave a comment tell
us how cool we are we love you so much
and we will see you guys on the next one
[Music]
bye